to what extent are we maybe compromising
the future output of science I'll just
focus on physics but basically ascribing
maybe not the best kind of attitude or
cultural attitude towards those people
that want to monetize or want to start
businesses as well as be scientists in
other words we're not teaching them
those skills but we might also be
stigmatizing do you see it like a
benefit to teaching entrepreneurship or
you know some kind of skill set within a
physics department so my three biggest
predictors for entrepreneurial success
are grit bias to action and American
ability to kind of tell narrative so
grit is perseverance through failure
which many scientists actually do have
because most of the work you're doing is
iterating continuing to kind of develop
even after something fails biased action
is a little different where so much of
depending on what science we're talking
about you're doing careful planning
absolute on narrative is a guy like Elon
Musk who could show up tell you he's
going to do something and then not do it
and still get you to give him more money
and do it over and over again for 10
years and then finally he delivers a
product